and the base rate we just heard from the
bank of England has been increased to
three percent so that's a 0.75
percentage Point increase it's the
highest rates have been since 2008 we've
been saying that all year because we've
been in this period of historic low
interest rates the rates came down after
the financial uh crash they not really
started the rose before covid when they
dipped a 0.1 percent that's the lowest
they've been and we're now on this March
back up that's the eighth successive
increase in interest rates at the bank's
monetary policy committee meetings which
happened every six weeks which is where
this decision has been made we should
say that the context of this decision in
the six weeks since the last meeting
we've had two prime ministers two
chancellors and that loss of credibility
in the UK economic situation I'm not
sure if we can show a chart which shows
us the path of interest rates so I'm not
sure if we have that yet there it is um
and you can see they've you can see the
the climb back up when the uh the steps
here this skyscraper you call this chart
they look a bit more like a Machu Picchu
in profile doesn't it at the end there
of the years we said we've stepped up in
eight successive meetings so this gives
you an idea of what is happening here is
the bank in the face of soaring
inflation that's what's driving this we
have inflation above 10 what the bank is
trying to do here is squeeze demand in
the economy one of the tools it has is
interest rates its aim remembers to get
inflation down to two percent so they're
looking to squeeze demand to stop us
effectively spending more by taking
money out of our pockets through uh the
various by increasing the cost of
borrowing which is what obviously
particularly affects mortgage holders
and the idea is you will then lower
inflation and squeeze inflation and what
they're really worried about here is the
inflation that 10 inflation is literally
driven largely by uh at Rising energy
costs exacerbated by the war in Ukraine
the thing the bank is worrying about I
expect we will hear more about and more
from our correspondent Ed Conway who's
who's been in uh briefing from the bank
all morning it's very tightly controlled
he's not allowed to leave leave till
midday because it's so marketing
he is making his way if I know that from
you do it in a vault in the banks not
with the gold but it is a locked room no
phones very secure and he'll be making
his way what will be he will have a
sense of is what the bank is saying
about where interest rates will go and
what it expects to happen in terms of
GDP it's forecast for the economic
health but what they're looking to do
the worry consistently has been that
this imported inflation if you like
through energy costs becomes embedded to
use the terminology through Rising wages
we have a labor crisis in this country
we have more unemployed more vacancies
in the economy forgive me than there are
unemployed people that is increasing uh
the push from employees for more money
because it's harder to employ them and
of course they want their wages to keep
up with inflation the banks worry is
that becomes domestically rooted so even
when the energy price Falls and
hopefully that happens you've got
inflation to stay so that's what the the
rate rise in the blunt is intended to do
so let's just reiterate for anyone just
joining us at the bank of England has in
the last few moments raised at the base
rate of interest by
0.75 percentage points from 2.25 to 3
percent that's the biggest single
increased interest rate hike at four
over 30 years and it also takes
um the interest rates the highest rates
it's the financial crisis since 2008
doesn't it Paul I mean the worry
presumably here is that when we find out
a little bit more about the bank of
England's predictions of the direction
that growth is going to go into in the
country that we could end up with a
situation of still having very high
inflation but also very low growth and
there's this thing called stagflation
isn't there where you get kind of stuck
in this stagnant uh absolutely and it's
it's the it's an ugly word and it's a
pretty ugly economic state to be in the
bank room the last time uh or certainly
the last time the governor spoke at
length uh was expecting the UK to be in
the start of a five quarter recession so
expecting to be in recession now that is
the economy Contracting and Lasting
through all of next year now this is the
balance they're trying to effectively I
mean the bank does want to slow down the
economy that's what raising rates is
about it's trying to take the heat out
of the economy the balance is not
tipping
the economy into recession which starts
to hurt people even more there's what we
one of the things we want to see is
where is the peak going to be because
there's a hope that in rates and
inflation itself becomes
cures itself is a break on there because
the more prices rise the less we can
afford to spend so it it might dampen
it's funny but this is a balance that
this is why central Bankers are employed
to do this job and why it's such a a
tricky one but the intention certainly
is to try and cap this interesting two
to hear what they have to say about and
what the market says its assumption is
where interest rates will end remember
after the mini budget and all the and
the the what flow from that huge
increase in the cost of government
borrowing the markets were assuming
interest rates would be above six
percent
by next year and that will have huge
consequences for mortgage holders the
fixed rates are already above six
percent they have backed off that
expectation now is that it's perhaps
around five percent is where the bank
will have to keep raising rates
will this rate rise do enough to knock
that back